>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: WELL, THE PRESIDENT IS
WEIGHING IN ON THE TOPIC WE WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT HERE ON THE
PANEL.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE TVS ARE ON
DOWN THERE AT MAR-A-LAGO.
HE TWEETED.
JAMES COMEY JUST THREW ANDREW
McCABE UNDER THE BUS.
THE  JUDGE, THAT IG REPORT, WE
DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE THINGS
THEY HAVE.
BUT KNOW THE McCABE PART.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THERE IS A
CROSS-SECTION HERE OF WHAT COMEY
IS SAYING AND WHAT LYNCH AND
McCABE ARE SAYING AND HOW THIS
FACTORS IN.
>> JAMES COMEY A GRADUATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO LAW SCHOOL
SEEMS TO HAVE FORGOTTEN BASIC
LESSONS AS CHUCK JUST POINTED
OUT.
WE BELIEVE HE IS A WITNESS FOR
ROBERT MUELLER BEFORE ONE OF THE
GRAND JURORS, BUT HE IS REALLY
SERIOUSLY DAMAGING HIS
CREDIBILITY BY OPINING ON
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN BY
SPEAKING ON BOTH SIDES OF THESE
ISSUES.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT HE THREW
ANDREW McCABE UNDER THE BUS.
HE MAY BE A WITNESS IN A
PROSECUTION OF McCABE AND
McCABE'S LAWYERS WILL FOR SURE
PLAY THE INTERVIEWS.
WHEN HE WAS QUESTIONED YESTERDAY
AND SHOW THAT TO A JURY.
IS THIS MAN WORTHY OF BELIEF.
LOOK WHAT HE SAID LAST WEEK.
>> Bret: THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
QUESTIONS LEFT ON THE TABLE FOR
OUR INTERVIEW APRIL 26th WITH
JAMES COMEY.
HERE'S THE RESPONSE TODAY:
WE ARE CONFIDENT THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WILL CONCLUDE
IT SHOULD DECLINE TO PROSECUTE.
HOW DOES THAT GO WITH JIM
JORDAN.
WAIT A SECOND WHAT HAPPENED TO
MICHAEL FLYNN?
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE
POLITICAL PRESSURE IS.
THIS IS A LEGAL SITUATION ABOUT
THE FACT THAT ACCORDING TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, ANDREW McCABE
LIED UNDEROATH TO FBI
INVESTIGATES WHICH IS A FELONY.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY CONFIRMED IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2017 WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SHE WILL HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER THERE IS ENOUGH EVIDENCE
TO PROSECUTE ANDREW McCABE.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT HIS
INDIGNANT ATTITUDE TO THE RULE
OF LAW IN THE STATEMENT HIS
ATTORNEY IS PUTTING OUT.
CLEARLY THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO ANDREW
McCABE BEING THE ONE WHO OVERSAW
THE MICHAEL FLYNN INVESTIGATION
WHO ALLEGEDLY LIED AND PLED
GUILTY TO LYING TO AN AGENT NOT
UNDER OATH.
>> Bret: RUDY GIULIANI SAYING HE
WILL ONLY BE ON FOR A FEW WEEKS
TO WRAP UP THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> HE HAS SUPER POWERS.
THE ONE PERSON IN THE WORLD THAT
CAN WRAP UP THIS INVESTIGATION.